my next recipe takes the humble pancake
to a whole new level of flavor and
excitement
soft fiery and irresistible spicy
pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination
when it comes to brunches you don't have
to stick to the old standbys
these delicious spicy pancakes are
really great alternative
but more importantly so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more and then fresh ginger
slice them nice and thinly stack it back
up
and then just slice nice little thin
slices in there
and then keep that bunched up shake the
chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now garlic
nice now add olive oil to your toasted
cumin seeds
and then with the garlic ginger and
chili lovely
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but
the time i spent in india everybody was
eating something savory for breakfast it
was extraordinary
into your bowl and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in and look at the color
an instant change leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes
across the pan all the potatoes stained
i want them sort of absorbing all that
really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge season those
potatoes and it really helps to bring
out
the spice beautifully
[Music]
they're ready turn off the gas and let
them sit there and absorb all those
flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic
chili ginger and cumin seeds a touch
of salt and pepper nothing worse than
the bland
pancake
one whole egg milk hold the jug with one
hand
and whisk we have a secret to get that
really nice smooth paste
but whisking that egg first and brings
it together
and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in it really
helps it
not going lumpy look at that
milk here and the secret for me is to
have a nice thin mix
now just a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring a nice
crispy edge to the mixture now
just taste it
that's the texture pan on the larger the
pan
the better it helps to create a nice
thin even
surface i want that mix going all the
way around the pan
before you put the mixture into the pan
make sure
you give your pancake mix a really nice
stir
pan it's nice and hot turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
around
which is really nice and thin i want to
see the ginger
the garlic that's what i'm looking for
in there
now back onto the heat it only starts to
remove
from the bottom of the pan and lifts
itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles confirm that it's
just starting to lift off
the pan a little shake that releases it
and then just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the
confidence tossing
then use a spatula and turn it over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge
around the side the color on the pancake
is so important
now roll it around and just let it slide
out
beautifully
now for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully roll that
nice and tightly tuck it underneath
there
pull it back and roll
the delicious pancakes are ready to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat
just mix chopped coriander with natural
yogurt
that's really nice cooling agent sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious
spicy pancakes amazing
[Music]
addition takes as much time to write on
a blackboard as it does to cook
chickpea cumin and spinach koftas with
tahini dressing
[Music]
in a blender put tin chickpeas cumin
seeds
paprika and turmeric
and blitz to a paste
[Music]
next wilt spinach in olive oil and chop
finely
then add to the chickpea mixture
sprinkle in gram flour made from finely
ground chickpeas
then shape golf ball-sized chunks of the
mixture using a spoon
and rest in the fridge when ready to
cook
heat oil in a frying pan shallow fry the
coppers until golden brown on all sides
then rest them on kitchen paper to
absorb any excess oil
for an easy dipping sauce mix yogurt
with a dollop of tahini
and a squeeze of lemon and stir in
freshly chopped coriander
a mouth-watering dish that's perfect for
sharing
chickpea cumin and spinach coffees with
tahini dressing
time is chili chicken with ginger and
coriander
[Music]
start by chopping chicken thighs into
pieces
now on with the marinade chop garlic
ginger red chili
and lemon juice
[Music]
in a pan toast coriander and cumin seeds
to release their flavors
grind and add to the chicken
then pour over plain yogurt add turmeric
and season
mix and leave to marinate from 2 hours
to overnight
next fry chopped onions in olive oil
then add chopped garlic and ginger
ground coriander garam masala and
turmeric
tomato puree and butter
next add the marinaded chicken and all
the remaining marinade
and cook until tender finally topped
with coriander
marinated for flavor and cooked in 20
minutes chili chicken with ginger and
coriander
a simple stress-free wonder
to keep old dishes fresh and exciting
it's great to get spicy
my next recipe is a time-honored british
classic but with addition of spices
it's given a new lease of life fragrant
spiced rice pudding
i love cooking with spices but you don't
have to just cook
savory dishes using aromatics and spices
across desserts
takes your puddings to a completely
different level
first off our spices this is a fresh
vanilla pod
fragrant and packed full of flavor
use the back of the knife and flatten it
that removes
all those little seeds off the skin of
the vinegar pod
take your knife slice down the middle
and then when you open that up
the smell is incredible take the tip of
the knife
and you scrape inside and look
all those seeds dying to come out
that is incredible there are thousands
of seeds
still ingrained to the pods so put them
in to the casserole cardamom powerful
spicy take two little pods place your
knife on top
and lightly crack them cracking the
cardamom pods helps release all the
amazing flavor
cloves gives it that kind of aniseed
flavour with a lot of depth one
two three cinnamon stick
snap and in just smelling that level of
fragrance
you can imagine what the rice pudding's
gonna taste of turn on the heat
lightly toast those spices just a couple
of seconds
and what's going to happen is just going
to sort of enhance those spices in a way
that it just
draws out an even more powerful
fragrance
coconut milk in
sugar two tablespoons
milk
and then a couple of tablespoons of
cream bring it slowly to the boil
to allow the flavours to infuse and this
rice pudding reminds me of my time in
india
where i got really into that chai tea
fragrance because it was just so
delicious and so comforting
take a lime in the lime just cuts
through the richness of the coconut
gives it that nice little bit of acidity
goes fantastically well with the
cinnamon
and that fresh vanilla nice have a taste
now let's go up to the boil give it a
nice little clean
around the outside and in with the rice
use 200 grams of pudding rice don't wash
it beforehand
because the starch helps thicken the
rice pudding in the oven
and just turn that down to a light
simmer and the pudding rice starts to
open up and it absorbs
all that coconut vanilla
cardamom clove and cinnamon bring up to
the bowl
gently and cook it out three to five
minutes
boiling it rapidly the rice opens up and
it goes into mush so we want to keep
that nice texture that
sort of fragrant rice pudding on a
gentle simmer
next a little luxury i want to show you
how
i take this simple delicious aromatic
rice pudding to a completely different
level
here's what i do take two egg yolks
separate them now give that a really
nice
whisk
two nice tablespoons of mascarpone
cheese
whisk that into the egg yolks
just to it's nice and smooth
it's almost like finishing the rice
pudding in a delicious custard
turn off the gas add that into the rice
pudding
what happens it starts to enrich and
really thicken this rice pudding and
takes it to a completely different level
the rice is still not cooked it's
starting to go nice and soft you can
just see
how it's opening up but looks like rich
aromatic
lava bubbling away
finally great more citrus zest the lime
on top
roasted caramelized lime zest
on top of a rice pudding is phenomenal
then put it in the oven for 15 minutes
at 200 degrees
to finish cooking the rice and develop
the intensely aromatic flavors
look at that an incredibly fragrant
rice pudding how beautiful is that look
spices are a brilliant way of helping
classic dishes come alive
i'll guarantee you'll never ever have
had a rice pudding like this before
you